Welcome back to Curious Archive.
This video is the second half of my two-part
series on the biology of Horizon: Zero Dawn.
In the most extreme biomes of this world of
machines, ill-tempered titans, skilled survivalists,
and genuine terrors still await discovery.
Like the animals braving the harshest regions
of our current age, these machines have had
to get creative to endure the hazards of the
elements.
The environments are perilous, and the machines
that live here even more so, but sometimes
discovery requires certain risks.
And with mysterious robots that aren’t part
of the ecosystem awakening in the darkest
corners of the land, who knows what final
secrets are buried beneath the ground.
So, join me on the last section of our documentary-style
journey, as we conclude our expedition across
the uncharted regions.
In the dense jungles of the far south, a fearsome
storm batters the trees.
Typically, I’d wait until such weather passes,
but right now, time is of the essence.
For one of the rarest and most spectacular
machines of all has been spotted here…
A huge shadow passes overhead.
Above my position is the single mightiest
machine of all the skies.
A Stormbird.
They’re huge — with wingbeats so powerful
they echo like thunderclaps.
The Stormbird is not afraid of the hurricane
raging around them.
For this machine is the storm.
And unfortunately for me, these solitary beings
are highly territorial.
Soaring close to the ground, the Stormbird
crackles with electrical discharge.
At the heart of this machine is what appears
to be an electric field generator, and this
Stormbird is about to give me a zap.
My camera takes the brunt of the blast.
This is why you always bring extra recording
equipment.
Documenting a Stormbird in the middle of a
storm turns out to be an inadvisable idea.
Eventually, however, the storm calms down.
And after losing sight of me, the Stormbird
has also mellowed out.
In the warm light of dawn, it is easier to
appreciate the majesty of this ruler of the
skies.
Across the land, there are no machines quite
like them, and our sighting is a promising
start to the expedition...
Without the gloom of the storm, the true beauty
of this jungle emerges.
With just the right amount of sunlight and
nutrients, this tropical band of forest is
a paradise.
Yet even the lushest gardens have their thorns.
A chill runs down the back of my neck.
A shimmer seems to ripple in the morning light.
I don’t think I’m alone.
Something invisible is moving through the
underbrush.
For a brief moment, the camouflage flickers,
and the stealthy machine becomes perceptible.
This is a Stalker — a nimble hunter whose
sinewy frame seems designed in every way for
ambush attacks.
Their demeanor mirrors that of a large feline
predator, with each measured step hiding the
incredible speed they’re truly capable of.
And the Stalker can take their ambushes to
another level.
Through the use of optical camouflage, they
can project the terrain behind them on their
bodies.
This form of invisibility is almost perfect,
with only a slight bend in the light suggesting
the Stalker’s outline.
And as the Stalker moves, they leaves behind
small proximity mines that will detonate if
I get too close, alerting the Stalker to my
presence.
Trying to keep one eye where I’m stepping
and one eye on the underbrush is harrowing.
Yet I have discovered a single weakness — in
order to take in light, the Stalker’s optical
sensors must remain visible.
If I keep watch for these floating dots, I
should be able to anticipate attacks.
Yet knowing an attack is coming is one thing.
Surviving an attack is another.
One Stalker has evidently decided they’ve
waited enough, and goes on the offensive.
Uncloaking, they take a hurried swipe at my
head.
A close call.
Every part of the Stalker is built for combat,
from the metal claws and teeth of their front,
to the stinger-like blade at the end of their
tail.
I doubt this is a fight I can win.
Yet just as quickly as the Stalker appears,
they vanish, disappearing once more to wait
for their next opportunity.
I’m not keen on another surprise attack,
and decide to continue my expedition in a
region with a thinner underbrush…
I travel to the north, a region where little
vegetation grows.
Here, a vast stone quarry stretches along
the length of a canyon.
This colossal excavation project appears long
abandoned.
Yet somehow, the site still feels occupied…
A terrible rumbling echoes through the quarry.
Something is moving under the surface of the
rock.
For a brief moment, a gigantic machine breaches
from the sand like a surfacing whale.
Stumbling backwards, I witness the metal goliath
rise up and clamp their jaws where I had just
been standing, before diving once again.
That was a Rockbreaker.
One of the largest known machines, these agents
of destruction can shred through any material.
Like a sentient excavation drill, they use
this ability to ‘swim’ under the Earth’s
crust as a fish moves through water.
When they detect a sound, they move, shark-like,
to the source of the noise, and attack the
unlucky target from below.
If a target is difficult to apprehend, Rockbreakers
will briefly surface — giving us a chance
to look more closely at their anatomy.
While they might function like a fish, Rockbreakers
possess powerful limbs that resemble an excavator’s
shovel.
Tunneling animals like badgers or moles have
similar digging mitts that they use to create
their burrows.
The most prominent tunneling tool of the Rockbreaker,
though, is their massive mouth, composed of
an enormous roller-cone drill bit.
With this feature, a Rockbreaker can swallow
vast quantities of raw material each day.
Yet what goes down must come up, and the Rockbreaker
needs to regularly regurgitate processed stones
into the air, which rain down upon the surface.
With a Rockbreaker on the loose, this quarry
is as perilous as it gets.
Time to tiptoe away to our next location…
In the western desert, I spot a herd of antelope-like
creatures racing over the dunes.
These are Lancehorns, and while I only catch
a glimpse of them, they look majestic.
Yet they are clearly in a hurry...
And I soon find out why.
Out of nowhere, a heavy sandstorm sweeps over
the western reaches.
Stumbling through the storm, I find various
familiar machines are also struggling to press
on against the howling winds.
All any of us can do is keep moving and hope
the storm dies down.
But there is something in this cloud more
dangerous than the elements.
Stalking within the sandstorm is a terror
from a lost age.
A Corruptor.
Moving on four, scorpion-like legs, this machine
isn’t like the others I’ve seen.
Not a part of the larger machine ecosystem,
they possess no behavior beyond unreasoning
hostility.
Yet how did such a machine come to be?
This stretch of desert, called The Rustwatch,
is scattered with mysterious ruins.
It seems a battle was waged here long ago,
with many dormant machines of war now rusting
away in the sand.
Perhaps this Corruptor is the last one still
functioning — a thoughtless agent of war
from a conflict that ended a millennia ago.
In any case, I have a more current problem
— the Corruptor has spotted me.
Yet to my surprise, before the Corruptor can
strike, other machines descend upon it from
all directions, unleashing every attack in
their arsenal.
Like immune-system cells descending upon an
infection, the other machines seem to instinctually
see the Corruptor as a threat to the ecosystem.
It’s a surprising turn, but not one I wish
to dwell on, as the ensuing chaos has given
me the perfect opportunity to make a hasty
exit.
Yet while I leave the Rustwatch, I can’t
help but wonder if there are other long-lost
machines hidden away in the margins of this
world…
With the western desert and southern jungle
now charted, the greatest frontier of all
still remains.
Far to the north, the Frozen Wilds — an
immense mountainous region — beckon with
the promise of untouched wilderness.
Temperatures drop low in the forests and mountains
of these wilds, with the wind carrying cold
drafts of snow between the trees.
It’s a good thing I’ve come with layers…
Yet some denizens of this mountainous forest
don’t have to bundle up.
Rushing ahead of me is a herd of remarkable
machines.
Chargers.
These swift-footed beings are the champions
of the freezing alpine slopes, and are comfortable
on inclines most creatures wouldn’t dare
climb.
In behavior and general appearance, Chargers
are perhaps most similar to mountain goats.
Curiously, there are organic mountain goats
present in this region, in a rare instance
of machines alongside the animal whose role
they fill.
As herbivorous machines, Chargers spend much
of their time seeking out patches of vegetation.
Unlike some herbivores, though, Chargers have
an aggressive side.
When I step too close, the animals rush towards
me, kicking wildly to scare me off.
I certainly now understand why these animals
are called ‘Chargers.’
It’s a lesson I’ll be sure to remember:
better leave these slopes to the Chargers.
Moving to the valley below, I discover a landscape
of surreal, prismatic hot springs.
These natural springs exist in the modern
day, and tells me this is a region we would
know as Yellowstone National Park.
The bright, vivid colors in the spring are
the result of microbial mats around the edges
of the mineral-rich water.
And tromping at the water’s edge is a herd
of bellowing giants.
These huge, stocky machines are known as Tramplers.
With their massive head, neck and chest, Tramplers
look like no force on Earth could knock them
down.
With so much bulk, they seem to be less bothered
by the falling temperatures than I am.
Like the Bison of North America, Tramplers
are highly resistant to the wind and snow.
And for any non-elemental challenges, a pair
of huge hornlike structures keep the Tramplers
prepared for anything.
Tramplers also use these horns to dig up rock
and soil.
They work tirelessly, stopping only to change
location to another spot.
But for what purpose?
Soil analysis suggests that Tramplers are,
in fact, purifying the toxin-laden soil of
this land.
They filter the material they dig up through
a processing unit on their underside, which
glows with heat from its arduous task.
With each region the Tramplers pass through,
the immediate ecosystem becomes a little healthier.
But Tramplers aren’t always peaceful.
Highly territorial, these bulls will charge
interlopers with unpredictable speed.
If pushed, Tramplers will even use their processing
units to set the environment ablaze, scorching
the land they typically protect.
Wanting to avoid such an outcome, I stay out
of range of the herd’s optical sensors,
and watch them pass on…
Cresting the next hill, I witness a Tallneck
trudging through the snow.
It’s surprising to see one this far north,
but it seems not even the cold can slow these
beings down.
Or the trees, for that matter, which this
Tallneck seems to take little notice of.
I find it is comforting to see a familiar
machine in such an unfamiliar land…
Yet just ahead looms a machine that is distinctly
unfamiliar.
These are Control Towers, and unlike all other
types of machines, they look botanical rather
than zoological.
To my astonishment, the strange machine then
releases a cloud of spiraling drones into
the air that burst with bizarre, purple energy.
As it turns out, Control Towers act as the
unofficial hearts of the synthetic ecosystem,
with their drones helping to repair nearby
machines.
Their bizarre appearance is a result of this
peculiar, sessile lifestyle.
Why bother with locomotion, when your legion
of loyal drones can go anywhere you can’t?
While the undulating movements of these towers
subtly resemble the motion of coral, more
than any other machine I’ve documented,
Control Towers have no clear natural analogues.
Yet in repairing damaged machines, the importance
of their role in the continued health of the
machine ecosystem cannot be overstated.
And with such a vital occupation, Control
Towers are fiercely defended by the machines
they repair.
On that note, I think I’ve gotten close
enough already...
To the north, the snowfall has become heavier.
Like the sandstorm in the western desert,
a blizzard descends over this region in a
matter of minutes.
Even with my layers of protection, I’ll
need to find shelter if I am to survive this
onslaught.
In the distance, I spot a cave illuminated
with the artificial lights of the hunter-gatherer
communities who occupy this region.
Perhaps refuge awaits inside?
No such luck.
From the cave emerges a fiery machine.
This is a Scorcher, and they have taken over
this cave from its previous occupants.
Their tall pointed ears give them a vulpine
appearance, although Scorchers seems far less
skittish.
I suspect the snow is now the least of my
worries.
Waiting for an attack, I watch the Scorcher
crouch down — then rocket forwards, leaving
a blazing trail.
A near hit.
Despite living in a cold environment, the
Scorcher is an agent of the inferno, creating
devastating, if somewhat inaccurate walls
of fire.
I might be cold, but this is no way to warm
up.
Time to find a different shelter.
Stumbling through the storm, I happen at last
upon a snow-covered ruin.
The structure has seen better days, but I’ll
have to take my chances.
The inside is thankfully much warmer… but
what is this a ruin of?
A collection of forgotten animal statues in
the corner gives me a clue.
I’m standing in the ruins of the Yellowstone
National Park Visitor Center.
And these statues are, sadly, the last record
of their respective species.
Once this building falls, these animals will
be lost to time.
Through a crack in the wall, I notice the
snow outside has calmed down.
The time has come to complete the final leg
of my journey…
At the foot of the mountains rises a fortress-like
ruin.
This was once a hydroelectric dam, through
which great quantities of water still flow.
And stalking the base of this dam is one of
the most dangerous machine of the frozen wilds.
A Frostclaw.
Like polar bears, Frostclaws have muscular
builds and are practically immune to the cold.
Indeed, Frostclaws are champions of the ice.
Using a chemical similar to liquid nitrogen,
Frostclaws can create sharp spires of frozen
coolant — transforming the surrounding area
into a forest of jagged ice.
Much of the dam is covered with these glacial
stalagmites.
And this Frostclaw is not alone.
A Fireclaw has also made their home on this
dam.
This infernal machine is even larger than
their icy cousin.
And they are known to be even more aggressive.
The Frostclaws’ opposite, Fireclaws wield
flames much like Scorchers.
Frost and Fireclaws might not seem like they’d
get along, but surprisingly, these two seem
to tolerate each other.
With both a Frostclaw and a Fireclaw at this
site, close documentation is a serious risk.
Fortunately, the Dam’s ruins provide reliable
cover.
All I have to do is find a space too narrow
for the machines to fit through, and stay
hidden until the coast is clear….
At the very edge of the world, the final stop
on our journey is a bleak graveyard.
Like the wreckage of the Rustwatch, this seems
to have been the site of a great battle.
Yet who — or what — were the ancient humans
fighting against when civilization fell?
Tromping through the snow is a metal monster
unlike any seen before.
This ancient horror is a Deathbringer, the
last machine standing in this grim cemetery.
Like the smaller Corruptor I encountered in
the sands, the Deathbringer has no resemblance
to any fauna, and is simply a unit of destruction.
Many of its weapon systems are no longer functioning,
but it seethes with blind hate nonetheless.
Perhaps it was rogue units like this one that
were the cause of humanity’s collapse.
Or perhaps the Deathbringers were aided by
something much bigger.
Throughout my travels, I’ve witnessed many
immense metal tentacles snaking over the mountains.
These machines, known simply as Metal Devils,
have been in the back of my mind this entire
voyage.
No still functioning-units of this machine
are known to exist, but their proximity to
ruined battlefields raise suspicion.
I suspect these machines are responsible for
the doom of the previous ecosystem, and the
animal machines that populate this land were
built to return the world to a habitable state.
In time, these ruins will hopefully be forgotten,
and Earth will become the planet it once was...
Warming up in the temperate safety of the
Embrace, I consider all I’ve seen in this
strange future.
While a quiet sadness permeates throughout
the ruins of this world, the interconnected
machines that populate the land have given
the planet new life — so to speak.
I’ve heard rumors of a vastly different
ecosystem of machines in a region known as
the Forbidden West, and if passage to that
location is ever possible, perhaps someday
I’ll chart it as well.
But for now, the time has come for to return
home...
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.